[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation a global business
network where I work halftime we do
scenarios we work with corporations and
government and governments and
departments of government all kinds of
people mostly doing scenarios about
what's the sort of strategic environment
that these large organizations are
facing in the next 10 to 25 years and
what they usually pose to us is what
subjects do they really want to know
about and the answer is China China
China China in India and so and we often
have horrible shelters an old friend and
buddy from Bolinas days and things like
that in the Jerry Brown days he did a
book about Jerry Brown if Jerry Brown
had gone in higher in politics you'd be
reading his book about during horrible
is been in the thick of some of the best
public talks given in the Bay Area the
last ten years because he's been
organized them out of the School of
Graduate School of Journalism at UC
Berkeley and basically bringing in a
series of major intellects you not only
talk about what's going on in the world
going on in America
but going on with journalism and so he's
got a perspective not only on China
China China and China but a perspective
on how media and policymakers and
basically the global frame of reference
is shifting in relation to China and
China in relation to it please welcome
horrible shel
[Applause]
well welcome it's going to to be here of
this very interesting lecture series and
to have answered the call of Stuart an
old and dear friend who in ways that
have not always been apparent to me at
the moment it's usually way out in front
of things and then later on you kind of
come to realize how that was true well
tonight the topic is China and in a
curious way too I think China has long
been something of a long now there is
indeed no society that's had more
millennia of history and history that's
curiously rooted in a kind of analysis
in that it didn't it aspire to change
much it did change but it didn't aspire
to change in fact when things went wrong
it always looked back and looked back to
the golden age of the Joe dynasty when
things were exposed to supposed to have
been somewhat exemplary as expressed
through all the classics and that's why
it's such a curious fact that when China
entered the 20th century and the old
imperial system which was basically a
cyclical one the dynasties would rise
and fall and new dynasties would be
formed and they were trying to emulate
the best of the past but it is so
confusing that as China entered the 20th
century it sort of lost that gravity
that constancy the the sort of
repetitious --mess of its culture and
sort of slightly evolved and embroidered
form and it's took off on this
incredible tear of trying this trying
that trying something else
revolutions counter revolutions and it
went through this period of serial
cancellations of what it thought it was
that's a very difficult thing for a
culture or society to do particularly
one like China which was so deeply
rooted in its
past its traditions and had such a
profound respect for history and the
notion that in history was embodied the
model the truth of the future so in
short order we had the fall of the Qing
Dynasty in 1911 we had the may 4th
movement in favor of democracy and
science against the Confucian Canon then
you got john kai-shek the Nationalist
Party the Republican movement a kind of
a mixture of Confucianism and
Christianity of Western political forms
of governance and more traditional forms
and then of course Japan came in that
was the critical moment
and so that nationalist experiment
Republican experiment ended and you got
Mao and Mao was a totally different tack
it was an imported ideology from Russia
Europe and China set off ultimately
before 1949 in the so called liberated
areas and then in all of China on this
incredible sort of magnificently mad
experiment of revolution and then you
got done shopping who in effect came on
board and it was interesting because I
first went to China while Mao was still
alive and while the Cultural Revolution
still raged and it was very interesting
to have been able to do that and
establish that as the baseline against
which everything thereafter happened so
then dung shopping comes in you know he
was the sort of the epitome of
rationalism search truth from facts
black cat white cat what does it matter
as long as it catches Mouse mice you
know let's get it done let's not be too
political and in effect it was a
counter-revolution one that goes on
today the Antichrist was let into the
Cathedral capitalism and yet the
Communist Party continued to rule and
then we have several other leaders since
dong - who have been sort of variations
on the theme
but if you look back over that stretch
of that century of history you find a
society sort of in search of itself or
in search of some other way to be and
that I want you to remember because it
is a kind of an uncertainty principle
that lurks behind all of the
extraordinary dynamism change all of the
cities skylines you see when you go
there the amazing facts of life which
you're all familiar with in which bring
you here tonight you know how are they
doing it if you were a little bit
confused though about what this whole
proposition is all about well you've
come to the right place now I'm not
going to answer it for you but I'm gonna
try to help you think through it in a
way that may help you make a little more
sense about what are the dynamics in at
work in this society
it's a greatly hopeful Society in many
ways increasingly wealthy increasingly
innovative entrepreneurial increasingly
confident indeed it's increasingly
arrogant and in a certain sense it is as
extreme a society today as it was during
the Cultural Revolution except rather
than having politics in command the
market isn't command profit isn't
command
Chinese do seem to have a curious way of
when they try something they go out at
hammer and tongs there is a kind of a
total ISM to the experiments that
they've they've undertaken over the last
century and you know that that that is
something that is worth bearing in mind
now let me just tell you what I want to
do here we can't tell where China's
going exactly but we can see where it's
been and we can define the various sort
of dynamic elements that are at work in
the society I mentioned the fact that
probably some of you are a little
confused about how to factor in all the
things you hear about China that make it
seem like such a
I call a boom of just amazing
proportions that's enabled it to flood
the world with with produce and and
goods and has enabled the middle class
to rise etc etc we'll get into that but
on the other hand there are an awful lot
of things that are very destabilizing
that are unresolved that are causing a
tremendous amount of anxiety and a
nervousness within China indeed the key
word to remember here is unresolved and
the China is a place where if you are
not accustomed to sort of a multiple
personality and if you're not accustomed
to maintaining several things in your
mind at once that are opposite you
probably won't have a very realistic
appreciation of this place so the
contradictions are all real and each of
them implicit within them is a different
scenario a different future and that's
important because everybody wants to
kind of come to some term in terms of
well alright which is it which is most
likely tell us
I mean business wants to do due
diligence government's want to do their
form of appraisal of what's happening
what are the trends I think it's very
difficult to do that in the case of
China in fact it is by a long shot in my
view the most unresolved nation and
society of consequence in the world and
it is that because it is in between
things and it is molting out of not just
one system not just communism Marxism
Leninism Mao's revolution it is also
molting out of Confucianism moulding out
of traditional forms of governance and
ways of seeing things seeing you know
leaders seeing wives husbands children
families you name it so it's got a huge
amount of contradictory baggage which is
trying to evolve out of and it's very
unclear where it's going I have a friend
who at one point I remember asking
what he was doing and he said well he
said I'm in between transitions and I
think that that perfectly captures where
China is today so I want to sort of
excuse your your your whatever sense of
uncertainty you may have about how to
analyze this country here at the outset
all right now let's consider just a few
basic facts here it's got a population
of about 1.25 billion people roughly
could be 1.3 the margin of error in the
census of China is equal to the entire
population of France that just kind of
gives you an idea what we're dealing
with here yeah there's an army of 2.5
million people it's the largest standing
army not the most technologically
advanced the largest army in the world
it has roughly 800 million peasants but
it has an increasing number of those
peasants coming into the cities indeed
big cities like Beijing and Shanghai
have about you know a third of their
populations are peasants who come from
the countryside what they call floating
population it has a hundred and sixty
cities over a million people I mean I
wager I don't even know three-quarters
of them and probably never heard of them
another statistic that this is somewhat
eye-popping it's the world's largest
consumer and one could go on and on and
on but of agricultural and and
industrial goods and of all different
kinds it has lots of cheap labor
although it seems that it might be
coming to something of a the edge of the
envelope in a certain respect on that
and if you don't fully understand the
power of cheap labour go to Walmart my
family and I we always play a game when
we go shopping at Home Depot or Walmart
or wherever we go to see you know you
look at the thing and you you say
alright give me odds was it made in
China and
there very few things these days as you
well know that aren't made in China and
even fewer that are made here this was
once the sick man of Asia it's now been
substantially reborn okay how do we
analyze this I'm gonna do something that
I hope will help you make a little sense
out of the contradiction I want to try
to argue first of all on the bright side
the good scenario China the miracle
China the boom the indestructible force
of the future and then I want to turn
around and put on another hat and and
and show you some of the weak points and
then we'll see what we can make of that
china now has peaceful borders with
almost every country that surrounds it
that that used to have you know four is
a head of four thousand mile border with
the Soviet Union and there were you know
myriad Soviet divisions encamped it was
a very hostile border no no longer they
had a war in 79 with Vietnam relatively
peaceful now it's quite an
accomplishment they've had a peaceful
transition to two leadership's following
dong shouting it's not exactly a
political system we would recognize no
one quite knows how the leaders come to
be chosen it is sort of a consensus
building process but that is quite
impressive whether they can continue to
do that or not is another question
because the it is an a systemic
political system they are as you know if
you open your paper there on the march
in Asia Latin America in the Middle East
you know while we are hunkered down
squandering our fortune and all of our
intellectual firepower in Iraq they're
showing up in Chile Argentina you know
Africa they're doing setting up a whole
new series of Confucian Confucius
Institutes like the aliens fall says
they're marching around the world in
terms of soft power hard power trade and
interestingly enough you know when they
go to another country they don't ask
questions about human right
doesn't matter what kind of governance
if there's good business to be done they
do it
Burma Iran Sudan Venezuela all fine so
there's a kind of a new sort of rail
economic that they have adopted and this
means that they can move into areas
where Western countries the United
States would have some some problem and
this gives them an amazing advantage in
terms of global markets they've gotten
to be friendly with Russia they're
talking with the Vatican as you may know
they're the Catholic Church as in the
case of the Protestant church are under
the control of the Communist Party
they're called the patriotic Catholic
Church Protestant Church they do not
recognize the any connection to the Holy
See and the bishop does not are not
appointed by the Pope and they recognize
Taiwan that would be a great sort of
moral or sort of psychic coup if they
could get the Vatican to dump Taiwan and
recognize them and they've come very
close they are now playing a major role
in talks with North Korea they've
started actually to have a kind of a
ingenue role in some diplomatic
conflicts but they're still very wary
about doing anything then in any sense
would make it look like they didn't
fully respect and recognize the absolute
power of sovereignty as a sort of
defense against any foreign intrusion so
they don't want to do anything in North
Korea which would establish any
precedent of international powers
prevailing or invading or encroaching
that then might set them up at some
point as being you know subject to
similar kinds of foreign intervention
they have a very nineteenth-century
notion of sovereignty very absolute
we're not quite sure of the number 200
million people taken out of poverty in
the last 10 15 years it's pretty
pressive not quite joining the middle
cat class in every case but I don't
think there's been any society any
country that's had anything like that in
terms of the level of economic benefit
give or take 10 20 30 40 million there's
300 million people with cellphones
reception is great you can go up to the
foothills of Tibetan Lao doesn't clear
as a bell I mean they've really leapfrog
all over the landlines I mean our cell
phone service is it's just a pathetic
snarl of dropped calls and compared to
China's there are roughly 150 million
people online and that number just keeps
going up that an interesting question
though because how do you control online
media when you're in a party that's used
to doing that that's a problem we can
talk about that every year they graduate
350,000 engineering graduates that's
about five times more than us yes
they're bigger maybe their education
isn't quite as good this is one area of
soft power the United States still has
but I fear we are squandering it we
should have a massive program of free
fellowships and scholarships bringing
you know 100 200 Chinese students to
this country every year and we don't
it's just a patchwork of whatever anyone
can throw together if we wanted to
really influence people we do that but
we don't have such a thing
and we doubtless will not have it
anytime soon
Shanghai has just for example a few
little factoids the largest shipyard the
largest ferris wheel the tallest
building I think this is a gbn factoid
that I found in some book and they also
have the fastest train I think it's the
only maglev magnetic levitation train in
the world that the Germans built for
them coming in from the airport and
they're talking about building one out
of Beijing or you
to do more it's quite astounding the
infrastructural projects they've
undertaken they have plans for the
tallest building they are the largest
producer of steel cement called
dot dot dot dot dot one could go on they
garner every year roughly a third of the
world's foreign direct investment it's
an amazing statistic yes they have
problem with their banks and with their
own financial markets but still that's a
quite a statistic annually they have a
17% increase in the rate of production
not that now all of these numbers are a
bit bit spongy I admit no one quite
knows whether to trust them or not but
you know give or take it gives you an
idea of incredible growth if you've been
in China recently you'll see the amazing
amount of new construction that
airport's terminals train stations and
railroad lines and I think the most
impressive thing at all of all is the
freeway system if you get out there and
start driving around China it's quite
astounding when I first went there there
was nothing but two-lane highways you
know and peasants would throw their
wheat out on and the trucks would win it
as they drove over and you'd creep along
at 10 miles an hour
of course there wasn't much traffic
either but now it's an entirely
different situation they've managed to
do what this country did in the 50s
which is to really build very impressive
and well-built trunk roads across the
country the United States somebody told
me it was actually negative but the
statistics that I've seen we have a 1
percent savings rate you know what
China's is it's about 40 percent now
there's a reason for that too because
the welfare system is so bad they have
to save to look after themselves but it
of course it bespeaks of the the other
obvious fact which is we're borrowing
money is China buys t-bills and our debt
is being subsidized by China so we can
buy we can go to
it's a kind of a codependent
relationship on the one hand it does
sort of work on the other hand there all
sorts of things implicit in that
relationship which could be very
dangerous and of course finally China
has a growth rate that 9 10 11 sometimes
12 percent that's staggering yep Japan
was hovering around zero one percent you
know if it gets up to three percent boy
that's you know that's great but here's
China chugging along
worrying about overheating not being too
cool
there is a huge trade surplus and most
of it with the United States is this
good or bad for us well many people are
worrying about it this August it was an
eighteen point eight billion dollar
trade surplus for the year and it looks
like it's gonna head up to 135 150 even
foreign exchange reserves are very high
almost a trillion dollars around 900
billion at this point they have in our
t-bill account about two hundred and
fifty and rising billion dollars of
t-bills that's a lot of leverage over
the world's most powerful country and if
you go to the cities you know it's hard
not to be impressed you look at the
Olympic Village that's being built this
really quite beautiful beautifully
designed an Olympic Stadium I mean I
don't think America could could
construct something on that scale now we
try to build a bridge and it's a big
deal one company built on that bid on
that bridge and it soon it'll be the
Chinese who are building that bridge we
are losing our ability to do that kind
of infrastructural problem and China's
role in the world is growing it's
getting a much better reputation it is a
more constructive citizen and people are
quite impressed and
some cases worried by it all right
that's a good scenario at least so far
what does it suggest about the future
well let's talk about that now I'm gonna
put on my other hat and I want to
completely bum you out and I want to
sort of turn the thing over and allow
you to look at the seamy side of China
that part of China which is can be seen
as quite dysfunctional and actually
menacing of this grand experiment China
has only 7% of the arable land and of
course a quarter of the world's
population bad start and a lot of that
arable land has been gobbled up in
industrial parks and you know for
railways and freeways and and and
various other construction projects
they're not going to be self-reliant and
food in fact what they tend to do now is
import food for the coast and they're
more self-reliant for food in the inland
area so they don't have the
transportation bottlenecks car
production and this one way is a good is
a good scenario statistic but from
another way is a bad scenario statistic
mm they made 640 thousand cars 2005 3.1
million and this number is just
skyrocketing and those of you who've
been to China knows no there isn't a car
company in the world that isn't trying
to get in there there are a lot of
Chinese companies that are also building
local cars and every city is just
crushed with traffic it doesn't that
matter how many ring roads they build
around Beijing you still it's it's
gridlock during rush hours it's a real
problem and you also know the
consequences of automobiles not just
traffic a small fact that just throw
away chopsticks take some 70 million
board feet of timber every year you know
anything that China does is on the
gargantuan scale because of the
the population 2/3 of all its energy is
cold that's a very significant figure
because coal is king in China and as
China turns and the world turns will
have to be mindful of coal because that
is what keeps this whole gyroscope
spinning it is also what could threaten
the world in terms of climate change
acid rain and various other kinds of
pollutants already in China because of
call largely in to some extent other
other automobiles 30% of the country has
severe acid rain that's a very that's a
very serious number people estimate in
Academy of Social Sciences some four
hundred thousand to a half a million
people have premature deaths because of
the air pollution if you've been to
China you know you can go for weeks in
big cities and never see the sky I had a
very interesting experience lately I was
there I think it was May and my kids
were in school in China and they had a
vacation and we wanted to take a little
vacation tour so we got a van and got in
and had a friend and we went out to
Shanxi province which is sort of in the
northwest which is coal country and I
thought well you know we drive outside
of Beijing go get past the Great Wall
you know then we'll see the sky
well we drove for I know it's four or
five days never saw the Sun never saw
the sky and in fact when you get beyond
the Great Wall and then you get into
coal country what you see is one power
plant after another one cement factory
after another one sort of industrial
plant burning coal indeed in China every
week now and again I've heard different
statistics one new coal-fired power
plant comes online I've also heard a
statistic the other day that said -
doesn't matter a lot those power plants
are not retrofitted with anything and
they are going to be there for 30 years
whatever their actuarial table is on a
coal-fired power plant and it's a huge
problem seventy-five percent of China's
lakes are polluted and there is serious
desert if ocation deforestation causing
floods and various other sorts of
dilemmas 75 percent of the river water
adjacent cities is undrinkable and in
many cases it is unusable for industrial
purposes and what is even more shocking
is that an alarming number of rivers
have stopped flowing to wit the Yellow
River which stops flowing in the summer
about two hundred miles up from its
final Delta and as I drove across as
Shanxi Province in May I didn't see a
single river with any water in it you
pass bridge after bridge after bridge no
water so the ground table is being
pumped out it's the only it's the only
refuge for for industry and people who
need water and I should also say that
landscape in that province which I
visited a number of times and and first
time long ago was one of the most
desecrated landscapes I've ever seen in
my life
piles of coal everywhere fly ash you
know cement factories with wind sort of
whipping the lime powdered limestone off
of piles like the off the face of
Everest and you would go for mile after
mile and there would be these incredible
occlusions of junky little shacks with
restaurants and truck stops you know the
soil saturated with solvents and oil and
then all up and down these roads
thousands and thousands of coal trucks
there's an article just day before
yesterday in The New York Times about
this coal trucking industry in fact
coming back into Beijing it was May Day
in the communist holiday and all of the
coal trucks were being kept out of
Beijing
they had to wait for a couple of days
while the holiday got over and so there
were these are models of these trucks
with truck drivers you know thousands of
trucks just stopped along the road
waiting and you've got a sense of the
the incredible the staggering dimension
of this energy question for China the
one that coal is the answer because
China has a lot of coal
unfortunately it's you know very high
sulfur content which coal and I should
say that the mining industry in China is
extremely primitive and they're
thousands of deaths every year of miners
is very unregulated and the Shanxi coal
barons are of course famous for their
wealth and they all live in Beijing and
drive big black cars but you know
China's got the needle in its arm but
then so do we 16 out of the 20 most
polluted cities in the world are said to
be in China I've also heard six out of
the ten most polluted cities I mean in
China you hear a lot of statistics that
sort of blow your mind and you don't
know which is true and sometimes they
conflict but most of them are on the on
the uphill side of astounding the
trouble with the these environmental
statistics is that a large measure of
unrest that isn't unfolding in China
grow out of environmental questions they
also grow out of corruption confiscation
of land by officials but the environment
is increasingly a cause of great
restiveness pollution you know rivers
being contaminated Fields being taken
away from peasants air pollution one
thing in another toxic dumps you know
coastal
waterways coastal habitat destroyed and
this is this is a something that the
party is getting very concerned about in
fact last year by the party's own
admission there were 87,000 instances of
notable public unrest that isn't just
somebody standing with the picket sign
the year before as I recall a figure was
74,000 that's very high year before that
I think it was 50 or something it's on
the rise and there are a lot of
different reasons causing it corruption
is a big problem in China and one of the
reasons corruption has such purchase on
the way things are done in China is for
this reason when the revolution came
about the Communist Party confiscated
everything all buildings all land
everything was nationalized and nobody
was nobody was compensated now that the
market is on fire
this land these buildings are worth a
fortune and the people who control them
control these state assets our officials
that don't get paid very much and they
get in league with the banks and form
projects and they are the wicket keepers
for what land gets sold to who and what
goes into what project and there's a
huge temptation and a huge prospect to
make an awful lot of money it would be
as if the government had owned
everything here and it set it back into
the economy in the marketplace with
officials determining where it went and
and profiting from it it's a very odd
situation in China because it's still
there's much state-owned enterprise and
you have the anomalous situation where
you know the army or or or the Air Force
or the Public Security Bureau will own a
hotel or a series of restaurants or a
whorehouse or a casino or whatever it is
they're they're playing so it would be
as if the Department of Environmental
Protection here had a string of golf
courses to raise a little income on the
side it's very curious and I've never
seen any reputable economists a
dressed that that situation of the state
ownership and the way in which the state
feeds property into the sort of the
private side of the marketplace how that
influences the economic picture I mean
how do you build that into a model
people estimate reputable economists
that somewheres between eight and twelve
percent of GDP should be written down in
terms of our environmental cost albeit
perhaps long-term rather than short-term
that's a very high figure that's almost
the entire growth rate of China and it
is alarming because it suggests that the
law in the long term there's going to be
a real cost that in other words they're
burning up assets now which they'll come
back to pay for later on
[Music]
now it's also a Lenin estate lest we
forget
China is reformed economically it hasn't
performed politically and the real
question is what does it do with the
institutions that are sort of on the
political side of the ledger that remain
if you walk to Tiananmen Square now from
the east you'll pass a giant building on
the Left hand-side just before you get
there right across from the Beijing
hotel and that is the new public
security building I mean it's vast not
badly designed either but the question
that you finally have to ask when you
think in terms of China's peaceful
evolution is what did they do with that
what do they do with the party what do
they do with the military what do they
do with the State Security what do they
do with the people's armed police what
do they do with these myriad
institutions which have hundreds of
millions of people in them how do you
how do you reform that that's a lot
harder to reform than some of the things
they've already tackled it's a problem
China has twice as many people as that
had 50 years ago real problem 12 million
new mouths each year new people to get
jobs for it has an aging population very
much weighted on the side of people who
have now retired it also has a very weak
pension plan it used to be that
everybody's welfare was taken care of by
their state enterprise you worked in a
factory you had health care your kids
went to school there you got an
apartment they took care of you you get
married you die they got you a coffin
when you got sick you went to the
hospital and you got a little pension
when you were when you were retired that
is melting away and they have not
managed to reconstitute a pension
program that really can do the job
that's why there's such a high savings
rate that's a real problem there's a
broken health care system used to be
health care was free but that it came
with your unit now hospitals are
increasingly privatized or they will
take you out of the commonweal and there
is a price for an appendectomy but you
will never get that appendectomy
performed unless you you slip a
substantial amount of money to the
doctors under the table to get on the to
get on the on the schedule and they
don't quite know what to do with that
it's a it's a it's a dilemma of
transition the new system is not born
the old system is not working banks a
real problem huge amount of loans out
that the state has made banks give banks
are not commercial banks in the sense
that we know them that they do due
diligence they look at an investment in
terms of risk and then they make the
loan banks very often have to make huge
investments just to satisfy the
government they're trying to wean them
away from that but constantly the
government requires this to happen
because they fear instability they don't
want to let a state-owned enterprise
with 50,000 employees collapse if those
50,000 people are going to be out in the
street
so they loan it more money so the non
performing
and banks are huge stock markets
traditional ways you all know that a
capitalist society raises money you sell
stock you have a company you sell stock
china has two stock markets and there
they've grown but they're basically
casinos that get manipulated in a lot of
ways and one of the biggest problems of
these stock markets is that companies
early on learned hey let's issue stock
and we'll get a lot of money and we'll
all buy cars and we'll buy houses and
it'll be great and they did but one of
the things they couldn't do because the
market was so small they couldn't put
all their stock on the market they call
it overhang so 1/2 2/3 nobody quite
knows of all the stock that companies
own isn't on the market and the
government won't let it go on the market
so in effect what you have is a rigged
market a market that doesn't operate
according to market principles but that
is being controlled by the government
and if the government feeds a lot of
stock and the market usually goes down
so it's a it's a how do they get out of
that trap nobody quite knows but without
financial markets to finance their own
development they're forced to rely on
the banks and outsiders so it's a
strange system that's not like anything
you know Finan Sears here would
recognize I might add that doesn't
weaken the ardor of many investors who
you know in my experience many of them
don't really want to know what's going
on they just want to get in they figure
they cannot but be there and some of
them make money and a lot of them have
come a cropper because the the powerful
sort of psychological urgency of getting
into the largest and most dynamic market
in the world and then you know you have
things lingering around in China like
the legacy of 1989 that undigested
massacre that moment in history is
greatly tragic that nobody has been able
to
to rest it's like an onion turd corpse
does it matter well it all depends on
what you think I mean does it matter
that human beings or societies come to
terms with their past doesn't matter
that you know Billy Bronco down on his
knees in the Warsaw Ghetto to apologize
for what the Germans had done during the
war
who's to say does it matter that the
Japanese repent and apologize I think in
some deep way it does and there is no
nation that has avoided its history more
sort of consistently than China and can
it escaped finally what it's done can it
escape what the party did to the people
whether it's the Great Leap Forward 30
million dead and famine whether it's the
Cultural Revolution whether you name it
doesn't matter that can you just take
that and say listen let's not talk about
it let's not we got a good thing going
here let's not dwell on it
you know depends on what you think is
important and what you think is a state
of health for for a society so I could
go on but I won't there you have these
two very interesting sort of panels of
facts phenomena dynamics and there are
many many others I haven't gotten to on
both sides of the ledger now you've
probably sort of forgotten the first
group at least the the that sort of
light bulb burning in your mind after
you turn it out it's probably dimmed a
bit as I've gone recounted this other
group so how do we reconcile these two
these two kind of very contradictory
lists of conditions I don't think we can
I think what one can think in terms of
is this that the best possible scenario
for China is what the party is very wary
of a hearing called peaceful evolution
that means peace filled piecemeal change
don't shop hang when he was asked
you know where's China going he is that
an expression that's not very common in
Chinese you know more just sure Togo Ajo
where we're walking across that we're
feeling our way across know we're
crossing the river by feeling our way
over the stones on the bottom and it
does not you know the speak of a
tremendously highly evolved notion of
destination it's all in the process and
it's going there very rapidly and if you
want to talk to people about where it's
going you get a kind of
deer-in-the-headlights look and if you
then ask about well politically what's
the aspiration you'll get the same look
you know maybe a little more democracy
what does that mean well you know who
knows and the interesting part of that
aversion is this that having had the big
dream of socialist utopianism dangled
over them for so long
you know with all the steps of how to
get there you know the bourgeois
national revolution of this the that and
then they're going to get to paradise
you know I think the Chinese are a
little sick of the big picture a little
sick of grand visions and a little weary
at this point of charismatic big top
rulers who run them over the cliff and
so in a curious way not only does the
party not find it expeditious to speak
of grand visions of where they're going
but people to or just you know they
leave me alone let me let me redecorate
my bathroom you know let me get that car
just as long as everything's okay hey I
won't make trouble but as we know in
societies there are always troublemakers
and what we also know indelibly that as
long as economies are going up and
expectations are hopeful and people are
on the escalator which they are in China
now you can get away with almost
anything in terms of contradictions and
and unresolved you know institutions and
the lack of clarity of vision the
problem comes as inevitably it does and
China has been incredible
lucky that it hasn't come yet and it may
not come is in the cycles we know their
business cycles we know their economic
cycles and even more important we know
the world is highly fragile in its
construction economically and that some
perturbation outside of China could have
a very profound effect in China let's
just take something that could happen
here the housing market goes south
nobody can borrow money anymore they're
losing their houses and their credit
cards are run up they can't go to
Walmart they can't go to Home Depot that
could have a very profound effect on
China so the thing to watch out for and
the thing I think ultimately China fears
most well of course there are all these
internal problems that they have to deal
with but what they fear most is that the
economic situation will slow down to a
point where they'll have more people in
the streets and unhappy and they'll have
more people saying who we gonna blame
someone's got to be at fault well I
don't I have a job and that to me is is
is the main danger to look towards
because the legitimacy base of China's
based very narrowly on economics now
nobody much believes in communism of the
party or in fact the whole value system
is rather vague you know if you're a
Chinese who are you are you Confucian
you Taoist maybe you could be Christian
are you communist or you Marxist to you
Maoist are you don't Xiao ping so you
Adam Smith I mean what do you believe in
and where do you turn when you need to
know how to do something right how to
relate to someone in a proper way it's
very vague now very uncertain and it
creates a lot of not only instability
but a kind of a murkiness in in people
knowing what to do when push comes to
shove
maybe I'll just end here and we can have
some questions you know China is a work
in progress and it is a country trying
to molt out of one system into another
system that is not too clear and it is a
country that's had incredible success
and shows incredible promise and and
it's got an awful lot of extraordinarily
bright young people in China who have
immense capacity and yet there are there
are a lot of things that don't confront
other countries by way of dealing with
past business past institutions that
nobody quite has an answer for and that
makes it very interesting that makes it
probably the most interesting country in
the world but it also makes it a very
provisional country whose future is not
gloomy by any means but whose future is
not to let's say assured like you know
give or take Canada is going to be
Canada right growth rate will go up and
down France I mean you name it most
countries they could have some problems
even Argentina but they're they don't
have built within them the kinds of
structural anomalies and contradictions
that the China does and China's
challenge will be in somehow managing to
manage to keep evolving and to resolve
those in a way that doesn't cause any
sort of precipitous bump in the road all
right I'll stop here let's let's have
some questions and we're going to do
that
[Music]
here's a question from Garrett Gruner
it's been said that China is using
Singapore as a model is China keeping up
with Singapore's historic evolution if
they were to keep pace when would China
begin liberalizing politics
well I suppose then you would have to
ask the question when did Singapore
liberalize politics uh they've done a
little way to some degree they did but
still it's basically a one-party a
city-state and I mean they're they're
certainly more liberal in areas of
people's lifestyle and to some degree
certain degree in freedom of the press I
think actually that is the best model
and I think they once did aspire rather
ardently to be a large Singapore that's
cooled off a bit with the cooling off of
the whole Asian values fever when they
thought you know are kind of a
neo-confucianism revived there was
something special about being Asia Asian
and Singapore embodied that you know
another interesting model oh would be
career at Taiwan which were also
one-party Leninist states and didn't
mold out into a much more democratic and
and truly open societies but they're
that they each has their own conditions
and then you know you compare China with
India I mean India my god the things
that happen in India and nobody bats an
eye
you know the riot and Gujarat and killed
thousand people and it still in inside
of the newspaper if anything like that
happened in China it truly would be a
shock that I think they would have a
very difficult time sort of surviving
because it's more tightly wound it is a
control society India isn't if something
blows up in India people just say oh
well that's you know some state and
India's having trouble and let's just
keep business going as usual but China
it would be a shock in a way to the
pretension of the system the Leninist
model of the party to control things and
to control news and to control image and
and everything else
play that out a little bit you're
describing a very large consequential
and brittle
China yes I mean I think in a certain
sense politically speaking China is
incredibly brittle and the fact right
now we don't quite know what's going on
we never do and that's astounding to
this society of such importance could be
so lacking in political transparency but
there's crackdown on the press there's
crackdown on you know various kinds of
business mergers and partnerships
there's a there's a kind of feeling and
if you hang around China as long as I
have you can almost atmospherically feel
a sort of thing you know programs are
being cancelled something is causing
them to be very very nervous and we
don't really know what it is because it
factionalism is it Civic disturbances is
uncertainty about the economy I mean in
a certain sense
China's never been better this place in
the world has never been more assured
but these are the kind of things that
emanate from the kind of contradictions
I've described so suppose there's some
kind of crackdown what happens with 150
million people on the Internet
well the Internet is an extremely
interesting case where we see being
fought out the old propensity towards
control and the propaganda department of
the party is what controls the media
largely there few other organizations to
do - they see the Internet and they say
we need it we want it it's an engine of
business of innovation of communication
and the party uses it - great good
effect communicating with counties
communicating with provinces
propagandizing making you know the the
process of government more smooth but on
the other hand they're very wary of it's
sort of seditious aspect and that's why
when Google goes in they make Google
censor a whole raft of words from their
search engine when Yahoo which is an
interesting situation because they don't
own their China subsidiary there they
bought a partnership with Chinese
company Alibaba when they China demands
information on someone they don't like
they give it over to them and the guy
went to jail for 10 years when Microsoft
is asked to yank down a website a web
log off of its server here they do it
that's the price and in the meanwhile
they also do destroy their brand name to
some extent and I have to say these
companies have good companies they're
smart people they don't want to do the
wrong thing but the price of doing
business is that and the Chinese are
very very wary that kept the media out
of China you can't buy companies it's
very hard to be a media player in China
unless you have a magazine company that
does fashion technology things like that
tech stuff so the this is a real
question of the wicket keepers of the
information technology revolution and I
think finally they're gonna have a hard
time controlling it but I would have to
say to date we have a whole project at
the Graduate School of Journalism the
China internet project we watch this and
if you want to know more about it go to
China digital times on the net and it's
a whole website on China and the efforts
to deal with the Internet
but it is the heart of the matter and we
see the old system contending with the
new it is the perfect petri dish
for the kinds of contradictions I've
been talking about okay here's maybe
another hard edge soft edge question
Eddie moley oh no it's here somewhere
right over there what do you think of
overseas Chinese and their relation with
the mainland and there's a huge diaspora
it's been going on for a century or two
yeah I know overseas Chinese you know
having come from China and this and this
I would to some extent include Taiwan
Macau Hong Kong you know they they were
sort of it's sort of like the Israelites
removed from Israel you removed from the
Holy Sepulchre
of their culture and there was a great
sort of tendency in a welcome and a
sense of relief when they could go back
to China invest in China and be
patriotic and they have and they proved
to be a significant engine for China's
growth but it's now reached the point
where that sort of intermediary role
that they played has been transcended by
you know you have everyone going in
there now from Walmart carful or all
these great big companies Home Depot so
they they play I think a less
instrumental role than they did early on
here's a question from amber Kerr area
yeah standing up and waving all right
there's considerable interest in China
right now but renewable energy
particularly wind are you up optimistic
with renewables will play a significant
role in China's future a talk we want to
have in the series and almost had this
month was William McDonough talking
about the greening of China because he's
been in the thick of being hired
apparently by the Chinese government to
designs five or six totally green total
cities and they they bought his book
cradle to cradle in vast quantities and
they're talking about a circular economy
and one of the scenarios you see coming
through gbn is a greening of China
there's so far hard over on the on green
reality but they're wealthy and
purposeful and they can move very fast
and you know they can build they can't
we can't build a bridge to Oakland but
they build anything they want including
green cities is there a green China
scenario well I mean there isn't in
these green cities I think of great
promise but there's a paradox at work
here to me everywhere you turn in China
I hate to say it there's a contradiction
and here's the contradiction for green
China you go to Beijing or you go to big
cities heard of provincial capitals and
you meet some amazing people in the
environmental field who are smart they
get it and you know they're working
extremely hard and they passed really
good laws and regulations and
looks all fired up and ready to go
however then you get down to where you
know the rubber has to meet the road the
local officials who are actually going
to implement these reggie's regulations
and it's another story so whereas in
this country we have almost a brain-dead
national leadership on the environmental
front but we have actually in many
states incredibly exciting interesting
programs our own state certainly being
being one in China you have
enlightenment at the national level a
lot of very smart officials who have a
very very very difficult time affecting
their policies locally why because that
12 percent growth rate and every region
is vying for every project they can get
their hands on nobody wants to slow
anything down with high costs with
retrofitting with any new technology
that'll raise the bottom line and that's
the dilemma nonetheless there are
interesting things happening but here is
the final outcome environmental
protection goes up this much you know
it's like this ok so environmental
protection goes up this much and
development goes up that much so even
though you have these very interesting
projects and efforts you're still
falling behind and coal is the demon you
had to put your finger on one thing and
China is not going to get off called for
a long long long time are you saying
they're not moving toward a nuclear
power they are but even in the most
hysterically optimistic scenario if you
happen to love nuclear power it's going
to be relatively minor for the near
future and thus it's back to coal and
you know there's some liquefied natural
gas there's natural gas from Central
Asia possibilities Russia and whatnot
but it still calls King and to fuel that
growth that's where they're going to
turn it's cost-effective here's a
question maybe on the good scenario side
from Kevin Kelly image right here unlike
most of Asia or even the rest of the
developing world China's cities seem to
lack significant squatter cities and
ghettos if true why I mean we had a talk
last year from Rob north about squatter
cities of the world there's a billion
people living in squalor cities all over
the world two billion more coming the
mega cities of 10 and 20 million some
going toward 30 million more than half
slums China's had 300 million people
moved from the country these peasants to
the cities just in the last 40 or 50
years and Kevin at least didn't see
major slums their story
well it's interesting there are these
sort of new cities of the floating
population that that get built up on the
outskirts of big cities and you know
they're they're not they're not like the
ones you see in the Philippines of
Brazil but they're constructed you know
freeform by people who have no homes and
those people until recently they've
started to acquire some rights they
don't have rights to be there there are
no rights to go to school they don't
have rights for healthcare so there are
some of these sort of they have water
and electricity and sanitary well they
bootleg it
they bootleg enough well I mean you know
and they they've come from villages
where they may not have had electricity
either so I mean it's it's amazingly the
the innovation that is used without you
know official city services in some of
these places this is the case that they
sometimes bulldoze those floating
populations well at different times like
during the Olympics I wager you'll see
some of these disappear and the other
thing they do which is very interesting
on construction sites they build these
dormitories right on the construction
site they they're not you know like
people in downtown New York living in
cardboard boxes but they're sleeping
three and four in submarine like bunks
and there you see them and they eat
right there and very simple very
primitive but it's worthwhile and so
that absorbs a huge number of people who
are actually working right on the
construction site okay I've got two
questions are related one from
and Harrison some demographers predict
that China's one-child policy result in
a near-term population collapse or aging
with enormous it cannot economic
implications do you agree with that and
a related question and then also the
question relates to the gender imbalance
because people are getting ultrasounds
and finding out what gender the baby is
and keeping the male ones a question
from Robin Sloane who's here somewhere
you mentioned that the Chinese political
process is mysterious so do you have any
insight into how a young person rises to
leadership is there class mobility
wearable China's next leaders come from
this presumably bears relation also the
demographic weirdness going on well it's
interesting
China's leadership now is almost
exclusively technocrats you know
engineers and people of that ilk a few
scientists it used to be of course that
China's entire leadership were humanists
they studied the classics they took the
examinations there were men of letters
they knew nothing about technology
banking science and then even during the
Communist period in the pre communist
period most of these people were highly
educated you know political philosophy
you name it that's changed and partially
because politics gets people in trouble
and if you are in the political world
the literary world you studied history
or something else you were certain to
have had some trouble and you might
still have a tendency to do things say
things think things whereas technocrats
are very matter-of-fact and and much
more rouille if you will so I think if
you were an aspiring young person you
either come up through the technical
fields or through financial business
fields and you keep your nose basically
out of politics there's one from John
Gilmore classic John the Gilmore
question is the turnover rate among the
Communist Party Central Committee higher
than the turnover rate in the US
Congress as rumored you know I don't
know the answer to that
has about 200 people and then there's
the Politburo and then there's the
Standing Committee of the Politburo they
shrink it down I think it's 910 people
not something like that and I don't know
it depends on what has just happened mmm
like after the Cultural Revolution they
would have hosed the place out you know
after 1989 you know there would be
winners and losers during the most
recent period of course who Gentiles
people will try to edge out Johnson ends
old people and there's all this
jockeying going back and forth but I
don't actually have a seating chart to
be able to tell you what the recent you
know change it's been a question from
Greg James out there something given
China's past everything's all right now
did it ever really think and plan
long-term and can yet think this is
going right to your title can't it think
and plan long-term now and if so how
well this is the another great paradox
how could a society that was so
consecrated to five-year plans and
visionary plans have gotten to walking
across the river by feeling their way
over the stones I don't think anybody
knows the answer to that it's almost as
if the Chinese leaders figure it's
better not to broach these questions
let's just keep going and we'll get
someplace it's sort of the mantra it's
almost more but no big ideas sounds a
lot like the Internet actually it does
have a kind of an incredible dynamism
and a capacity for infinite growth but
no clear end is the central nervous
system although China has a central
nervous system it's just they're not
going to do this you know you would not
get for instance on Chinese television
Ken Burns doing Thomas Jefferson you
know doing soon yachts in or doing it's
too complicated it's a minefield nobody
quite knows what the right version of
their history is anymore when Chinese
tourists go to the Great Wall
which I assume they do what do they see
what do they think I think they see the
same thing Richard Nixon did they say
that's a great wall and I think they
feel proud that it represents something
and you know there's the I think it's
untrue in fact that you can see it from
outer space Russell you're here can you
see the Great Wall from outer space
there's no us yeah no I think they feel
proud that so many people want to come
and see their Great Wall the truth is
most of the Great Wall is just a pile of
rocks and the part that you visit has
been carefully reconstructed so well Ken
Wilson they had the question and they
still do any 5-year plans they do they
have a five-year plan and you know the
sort of the description of what's
happening is socialism with Chinese
characteristics so the ideology now that
they that's that's what the five-year
plans are supposed to be aspiring
towards so you know the kind of the
ideological slogans like Jiang Zemin's
four represents and they're really not
you know big page-turners and they're
not calculated to be they do not want to
pin the tail on the donkey and say
what's what and where things are going
you know in the olden days they used to
think they think all jeong fung where
they would rectify the wind they would
rectify the names they would try to
bring the name of things back into
alignment with reality you know it's
things you know we have a problem here
in this country but the other way around
not describing reality but that's not
very much on the leaders Minds today
what happened the Mandate of Heaven that
was a title of one of your books well
you know it singeing the Mandate of
Heaven was this notion during imperial
times that heaven which had no God no no
sort of personification of the deity
conferred Grace on an emperor to rule
and the way you knew this mandate was
still conferred on the emperor was there
would be peace and harmony an empire and
if things started getting out of sorts
or there are earthquakes or peasant
rebellions then
one could infer that the mandate had had
laughs this is very much in the kind of
unconsciousness of Chinese today and
they know that there are certain things
throughout history because many people
know of these popular versions of
history that that there are certain
signs of mandates of heaven lapsing like
peasant rebellions cults you know boxer
rebellions you know red turbans etc etc
and that's why they're we're so afraid
of Falun Gong in significant measure
they this could be perceived by an
insurgent cult sort of the speaking of
the failure of the modern version of the
Mandate of Heaven conferring grace on
the party and its right to rule
unilaterally so there's all this kind of
stuff that sort of deeply ingrained
almost unconsciously and autonomically
in the system of Chinese that that
operates that everybody feels and knows
and it's very hard to describe and
foreigners don't quite get it but you
know it's all their peer related
questions one from Bart Milwaukee what
is being overlooked by thinking of China
as one entity and forecast how much of
an issue is Geographic disparity in
China's future given all these highways
and everything presumably they're trying
to address that that how regional is it
really well you know it's quite regional
even though they've been masterful and
tying it together with communications
networks economic power is can be very
regional and then of course there's all
of the ethnic division fault lines
whether it's Tibet and Buddhism shinjang
the west and Muslim areas Mongolia half
of which as you know is part of China
now that the Chinese gave away in 1926 I
think it was and then there's Outer
Mongolia which is now independent what
they fear because this is the last piece
of the Chinese kind of commitment to the
revolutionary platform namely unity of
this multi-ethnic state that's why
they're so rigid on Taiwan that's why
they were so insistent on getting
Hong Kong and Macau back and that's why
they just will not hear any reason on
Tibet they don't want this idea of China
reunified the motherland
you know after it was packed apart by
foreigners to be tampered with so there
it's a very important notion that has
also something to do with the Senate
that did this the brutal 'no sat the
system is there any chance you mentioned
that they were being very delicate with
North Korea North Korea could implode
any old time
did for China see that as part of their
old Imperium and something that should
be reabsorbed I think they're very
afraid that a little bit like West
Germany that you know East Germany was
all well and good to bring down the wall
but then you had to deal with all these
East Germans and I think just as the
South Koreans are very wary of what will
happen if North Korea explodes and they
suddenly acquire you know the care of
all those North Koreans China feels
exactly the same way there's a big North
Korean ethnic minority population in
Manchuria across the border and I think
you know the in South Korea's view and
in China's view the best scenario is
keep the lid on things don't don't do
anything that will jostle it too much
and let's just hope slowly something
happens the last thing they want is a
precipitous explosion well here's an
essay question from Bill Lightner
compare and contrast China in court or
sorry Japan incorporate its rise and
fall visa vie American economic position
in relation to China incorporated well
you know I mean the one thing to take
note of this do you all remember back in
the 80s when people were writing books
about the Rising Sun and the Japanese
were buying Rockefeller Center and
Pebble Beach and we thought Jesus what
are we doing wrong and you've got to
learn from these people we're gonna be
they're gonna suck our brains out and
walk away with our economy remember that
yeah well I'm not saying China
that's China's fate I'm only saying that
there is a kinda and you
remember the five dragons and then 1997
came and do you remember Silicon Valley
and the bubble that came back but it's
only to say that you know Japan has been
up and down and I think it would be most
unrealistic not to factor into some
accounting of the Chinese discussion of
scenarios any number of things which
could have a similar effect
I don't predict it I don't want it but I
would be anything very naive not to
assume that China's relation with Japan
now is very bad but Japan now has a new
prime minister who seems to be much more
dedicated to ameliorating that
relationship but I have to say China
does export a huge amount of sort of
grievance energy to either Taiwan or
Japan in other words don't blame us
don't seek redress of grievances in
Beijing blame the Japanese for World War
two and Nanjing Massacre and everything
else under happened and the Japanese
haven't been so accommodating about
making an apology like the Pope you know
and the Muslims there's a there's a kind
of a victim syndrome going on there that
to what degree do you go to to
propitiate it it's kind of hard to feel
sorry for that big and successful victim
I mean Japan yeah I was thinking though
China they're still playing that you
know the Nanjing was this horrible rape
that happened to us and why doesn't
anybody apologize well you know it's
very interesting that the the you raised
that Stuart because it is sort of
counterintuitive that a country now so
successful should feel itself to be
quite so vulnerable and to still feel
this victim syndrome but it just
bespeaks of the depth of that historical
experience and you know very often now
they use it less but it's still you see
it when China is making a grievance
against someone they say in Chinese it's
literally it's hurt the feelings of the
Chinese people it's as if they're saying
mommy he hit me you know it's not real
interest it's something
that is quite visceral so that continues
and and I have a kind of in my head a
kind of a little hot sauce thermometer
that I'm constantly trying to gauge the
level of that victim impulse because
it's precisely when China begins to grow
confident enough and outgrow that
feeling that it will then become a more
constructive and I think positive world
player often people go from the victim
role too arrogant bully role is there a
chance of that kind of flip going on I
mean there's some of that present now I
mean there is a lot of arrogance in
China now and a lot of talk about
America being weak and hopeless and
can't tie its shoes and declining
empires and China peacefully rising the
Japanese were saying less decade wasn't
it I mean you go back and you read these
books I recently did have a look at some
of them and you know you have to you
have to admit that when we get off on
the tear in believing somebody's got the
answer we can be pretty myopic about the
problems
here's a multiple choice question from
rusty Schweickart mm-hmm
the before you get to pick any two or
three what are the roles of the
following in China today one taoism
buddhism confucianism probably
Christianity to women three science
what's the role and the fourth one is
violence okay well let's try to go
through these one was the first one was
was religion right Confucianism
Christianity what else yeah Falun Gong
cult well listen Christianity is making
a big comeback and it's precisely
because there is a real vacuum at the
heart of the sort of the values belief
proposition you know the market is great
and people really have had a chance to
improve their lives and and and now
they're they're asking some deeper
questions you know what's the meaning of
life and so religion is really enjoying
something of a comeback this is true of
Tibetan Buddhism
is this organized religion or cults well
then at your own religion it's all kinds
you know in the countryside peasant
cults are kind of a strange mail ah of
taoism buddhism and local tutelary gods
and people go to the temple and pray to
get pregnant to get rich and there's the
door gods and the kitchen gods and one
thing in another but also in the cities
catholicism protestantism very very
strong particularly these house churches
which are the non patriotic party
sponsored churches at least mutually
exclusive vers it's sort of the old
china we could be partly Buddhist and
partly Taoist and partly whatever that
peasant sort of folk culture religion
tends to be that way and then there's
been traditionally a higher tradition of
more sort of philosophical Buddhism
Tibet would be an example of that and a
lot of people gravitate towards that but
usually it's more educated people who
take a fancy to that but there is a
hunger I think a deep hunger for some
some meaning that exists outside of just
getting rich
wait a minute you sit about to better
you suggest all we've been hearing as
they're crushing Buddhism in Tibet
this is Tibet it's Tibetan Buddhism sort
of seeping out anyway and well it's
gooey knees are seeping into Tibet right
so now to bet is a great tourist
destination for Chinese okay and there's
there always been a romanticization sort
of a mythic version of Tibet it's not
our version I wrote a whole book about
this but it's the Chinese version of
Tibet which is a place that's wild and
free and it's it's a crude it's a place
to which you get exile but it's also a
place where you know the Tibetans share
wives and they have these colorful
things and they gallop around and you
would see it even in the Cultural
Revolution and in stage productions in
the movies this this sort of kind of
fascination with this freer more
spiritual place and a lot of that
continues on today you see in oil
paintings one thing in another and
people go to Tibet and there there is a
you know considerable dimensions of
young people seeking solace in Tibetan
Buddhism well well well
how about women typically when the story
we've been finding is when people moved
from the countryside to the city the
women are liberated and become economic
players and so on is that happening in
China I think to some to a large degree
that is true I mean in in urban life
women tend to be much freer in in the
countryside there's been a kind of a
retrograde motion to the old way of
doing things that center around farms
and since peasants now have they don't
own land but they have long-term leases
to land as if they owned it the old
practices of family houses and women and
grandparents in the same house are
substantially restored they had been
completely wiped out of course during
the Mao years by communes so that's the
case and in terms of kids people in the
city tend to have negative growth
because they have one kid housing is too
tight but in the countryside where they
have land and food they tend to have
many kids right so and also this
disparity I think you mentioned you
asked about earlier between men and
women it's creating some real problems
because they're they're going on long
enough that most it they're sort of
getting of dating age what's going on
well it's a problem and I think it's a
hundred to a hundred around 110 to 114
in other words for every 100 men a
hundred women there is a hundred and
fourteen hundred and ten men right so
what's happened is there's a deficit of
women and so there there are there's a
substantial amount of kidnapping of
brides you know simple young women girls
in the countryside and they'll transport
them thousand miles away and sell them
and the old tradition of wife of wives
being sort of chattels anyway and being
sort of almost sold off or at least
dowered off it's still quite strong in
the countryside and some of them don't
speak the dialogue and don't know how to
get home and there's a brash of suicides
in the last decade or so of these young
women who are utterly despairing and
they drink rat poison or pesticides or
something and kill themselves it's it's
quite quite serious and and and it's not
a nice this isn't a kind of an isolated
phenomena the use the last arrestees
here science now there's all these
religions but presumably there's no
religious aversion to science or is
there no that I think mercifully has
ended you know the old sort of life
saenko debates had their analogs you
know 10 15 20 years ago in China but I
think China's problem now in regard to
science is not that people aren't free
to do good science and research it said
that the kind of education that the
Chinese specialize in namely
memorization rote work doesn't always
encourage this sort of bold scientific
sort of preposterous thinking the
critical thinking I mean scientists are
always trying to disprove things find
something else out you know following
hunches that may be intuitive that comes
somewhat harder to Chinese I mean
they've had this tradition of a bang
memorizing of doing what they're told
and I think they they do lack that
dimension that animate scientists in the
West the very highest and most sort of
imaginative levels in last two questions
one from Aeryn Zim should I learn
Chinese Mandarin or Cantonese and is
that is there any hope that the state
will adopt a romanized orthography well
they've tried that at different times
and there are romanization z-- but they
don't use them in within China should
you learn Chinese why not how old are
you you know it's pretty hard to learn a
language well at that age but if you're
willing to go there and hunker down for
two years you could get it and I think
it would be a very useful thing for you
I mean listen you can learn any language
after English
I would choose Chinese and we're maybe
Spanish you know whatever happens
China will now be of consequence and
Chinese economies can be of consequence
even if it runs into some very troubled
you know seas okay lent with a
journalistic question this is and we'd
like a scoop please understand we'll
read and then the art types in the next
few days about a new professional
assignment you're taking on next year
you want to say something about that
sure well lo these many years I've been
at Berkeley and I'm going to take up a
new post come spring in New York the
Asia society's gotten a very nice pot of
money to set up a China program we're
playing some a New York City Soundtrack
in the background so I will do that it's
a very interesting invitation and the
areas that I do want to focus on are one
media and second is the environment and
then of course some policy questions but
I think just as a final word
the one problem that is absolutely
unavoidable and around which everything
is going to turn in the next decade or
so is the environment and China and the
United States are that's it India too
but India is you know if we can't get
China in the United States to get into
konkuk into a common program on those
China watch the US did they watch what
we do in terms of environment yeah they
do and there's a lot of exchanges
because there are a lot of incredibly
brainy smart people as you know doing
amazing things in this country it's just
the government is dead in its tracks and
the Chinese are aware of a they have a
problem but Daleks going to be there yep
so actually that's part of what China
paid attention to is the u.s. is sort of
an workaround mode you have a psychotic
leader you just figure out how to do
stuff yourself right right I learned
that in the army it happens all the time
it's not a big deal all right so but is
trying to know enough not to pay
attention to the government who's stuck
back in the locker room and they're
paying attention to people actually
doing stuff or not yes but there's a
problem there Stuart because the China
is very worried about civil society and
what we have is this incredible
fluorescence of civil society working I
mean look at you know Branson just as
people are falling out of the trees now
you know throwing themselves at the
environment and it's civil society but
for China civil societies like home
churches it's independent it's dangerous
and they don't know what to do with it
so it's very difficult for instance to
get money to China for an NGO and if you
want to do something in China you know
it's incredibly complicated because it
has to go through all these government
vetting --zz so if you don't have a
government relating to government then
you've got civil society maybe relating
to government that's easier but civil
society the civil society which is where
90% of the action is now in China and
here is it's tricky it's difficult and
until you know China doesn't have a law
that allows the NGOs to exist so they
have all of these crazy systems you know
they register as commercial operations
and they pay taxes because they can't
register as an NGO I mean properly they
can do a thing called guaca-- where you
you take yourself and you you literally
hang yourself off with some other ng
some other institution that has
government sanction so this is this is a
real problem and I don't know how we're
gonna work all this out but it's going
to be a really interesting ride and
that's an area I think I'm sure many of
you will vineyard you'll want to toiling
thank you very much thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]